-Do you think we could finish by today?
-Yes, if we continue at this pace.
Madam, if you would.
Madam?
I'm okay.
Madam!
-I'm okay.
-But...
Please, continue.
-Stop! That's enough! Mommy!
-Miss Ann!
-That's enough!
-Ann.
I'm okay.
So, please go play in the other room.
Why are you writing this letter?
Who is it for?
Daddy isn't even with us anymore!
-It's an important letter.
-It's for someone I don't know, isn't it?
Someone who won't even come visit you!
No one really cares about you anyway!
Is the letter more important than me?
There's nothing more important than you.
You're such a liar.
I'm not lying.
But you're not getting better at all!
You said you were going to get better!
That's right.
I already know!
I...
I'll be all alone once you're gone!
How much longer
will I be able to be with you?
If I'm going to be all alone anyway,
then stop writing some letter
and spend time with me now!
Please, Mom!
Please!
-Mommy!
-Miss Ann.
Mommy!
Miss Ann!